joined now by chloe smith minister of
state for disabled people work and
health hi good to see you thank you very
much indeed for joining us on the
programme this morning here to talk
about a one-off disability payment of i
think 150 pounds how far do you expect
that to go
can i first of all say how really sad
that news is from liverpool and my
thoughts just go out to the the family
um
the
news we're talking about this morning is
really important actually to support
disabled people and it comes on top of
the
whole package that the government has
put in place to support people on the
cost of living so actually in totality
what we're looking at is the 8 million
most vulnerable households in the
country receiving at least 1200 pounds
so all in all i hope this is of serious
help to people in the face of rising
pressures which of course the government
acknowledges how far do you expect this
150 pounds to go
well it will make a contribution of
course and it comes on top of as i say
the other support as well so for example
400 pounds to all households on energy
bills so in the context of the kinds of
costs that disabled people face this i
hope will make a real contribution to
what people are facing the reason i'm
asking you minister is because we have
spoken to
a young man a disabled man who doesn't
want to give his name for obvious
reasons we spoke to him a week ago he
said he doesn't i'm quoting him does not
expect to be alive this spring because
of the scary cost of energy bills
well obviously i'm very sorry to hear
him say that and that's a very
concerning thing for somebody to say in
that context i would certainly hope that
all of the staff at job centres and in
other parts of the welfare system are
there to support him as they should be
and of course what a person may well be
eligible for by means of this payment
links to other benefits that they would
already be getting so for example
personal independence payments or
employment and support equipment so
there is of course the breadth of the
welfare system there to support that
particular person or others in a similar
similar set of circumstances and what
the government is saying today is that
in addition to those normal parts of the
welfare system there is this support
available in terms of the cost of living
because we recognize those rising
pressures and it's important to have
acted which is what the government is
inflation at 19 by january
these are very troubling figures and the
government agrees that these are very
worrying figures and that's why we're
acting with this package and of course
that's part of having acted already so
those who are on means-tested benefits
again for example employment and support
allowance will have received already
payments and that adds up to
over 1200 pounds
if inflation is at 19 percent by january
um this trust for you support is still
saying that a recession is not
necessarily inevitable she seems to be
the only person that's saying that at
the moment
well i don't think uh i don't think
she's she's alone in making the argument
that actually do you agree with her i do
agree with her because i do agree with
her because what we need to focus on
first of all is to be able to grow the
economy and she's been really clear that
that is her strategy and i think that's
right because growing the economy will
in turn
raise tax receipts and that is of course
what enables us to run the public
services that will support the person
you've given the example of and many
others so i do agree with her absolutely
this is the right overall strategy but i
know that she is also keenly aware of
the pressures that people are facing and
that's why she said she wouldn't rule
out doing more but she has to have the
full data in her hands but the tax cuts
that she's talking about will not
benefit
the least well-off in this country and
that's why she said she wouldn't rule
out doing more but again she has to have
the full data in her hands if she's
lucky enough to become prime minister in
a few weeks time she would be able to
look at the entire picture and she said
that she would be putting forward an
emergency budget and that's where i
would expect those decisions to be made
um as far as an emergency budget is
concerned just looking at my notes here
um she was reportedly planning that
emergency budget in september uh next
month um i think i'm right in say am i
right in saying that i believe so yeah
okay um the obr is giving an official
forecast the treasury committee chair
mel stride said she's flying blind
without having a forecast to work off
she doesn't want that or she's changing
her mind
i think to be fair uh okay you might be
trying to run several arguments at once
too because if you what would you like
to take if you were to say that
inflation is rising as you as you did at
the beginning of this interview and
obviously we expect the price cap
information to come in this friday there
is already a building picture there what
liz has said on the obr point in
particular is that she wouldn't wish to
delay any further by waiting for that so
they're ready to go they're very happy
to she will she will have to be able to
be in position and take the data that is
available and within that context she
then wants to be able to work as quickly
as possible but the obr have said that
they will offer an official forecast um
and uh she's saying she doesn't want one
is that right she she's saying she would
want to be able to use all the data that
is available when she were to become
prime minister so you and i are sitting
here somewhat in advance of that i would
love liz trust to become prime minister
for reasons that i've been
very clear on and i think she has a
really clear plan and a bold vision but
she will have to have all of that data
available at that time
then to be able to make her decision
tell me about her bold vision what's she
going to do to help people
well in the context of uh the cost of
living of course she will be uh she will
be um continuing to support the actions
that the government has already taken
and much much more than that and in the
context of uh
and the information i'm bringing to you
this morning of course afresh is that
the disability payments the 150 pounds
that uh we began by talking about those
will be rolling out from the 20th of
september so i hope that that new
information is of uh some comfort to
people that is part of a plan that gets
over 1200 pounds into the household into
the pockets of the households uh where
most vulnerable people live now that's
really important action in addition to
that as i've already mentioned uh liz
trust if she were to become prime
minister has said she said that she
doesn't rule out further help uh for
what does that look like vulnerable i
can't answer that for you as you well
know kate because that would be the
subject of her emergency budget that's
what people want to know indeed they do
and they will have to keep watching your
programme and others as the author
they're not going to necessarily vote
for her are they unless they know what
she's watching liz has already set out
clearly is not enough what liz has
already said out very clearly is that
she wants to focus on growing the
economy and i think that's actually
really important also in the context of
the cost of living because people do
want to be able to have a job in which
they earn to be able to support
themselves and their households and liz
has spoken and i think rightly about
wanting to be able to focus on helping
people keep money in their pockets for
themselves rather than removing it in
taxes and returning it in benefits and i
think that's perfectly okay what are you
going to do about the energy price cap
because quite a few energy bosses think
that it should be frozen and obviously
it's going to be looked at again and
soon and then also next january at least
three energy bosses that i could quote
you know them already for actually um
are saying that the price
should be capped should be frozen um if
they want it surely she should want it
i'm aware of those arguments and indeed
for example also the labour party also
makes the argument that actually there
should be a
type of a freeze i worry that those are
short-term solutions only so i think
what we do need to do i think what we do
need to look at is the longer term
solutions about how to bring energy
prices down and there you need to think
about energy security and there you
would also need to think i think about
the ways that we uh interact with
somebody like
vladimir putin of russia whose actions
have been a main part of driving those
prices up and driving those pressures up
now in elizabeth trust you have somebody
who's been i think the clearest of all
in saying that we should stand up to uh
putin for the bully that he is but she's
also been clear that in other ways she
will deal with energy prices so for
example removing the levy that people
pay and that will take 150 pounds off
bills now on top of that she's also
of course going to be listening to the
likes of quasi-quarten who has been
working in government already about
further things that can be senior
chancellor potentially that's for her to
decide but this brings me back to the
main point she will she would be in a
position to make those decisions if she
became prime minister so she's settling
it out i certainly
you've already heard her say that she
doesn't rule out further support and i
think that's right now what i'm here to
talk about this morning is how we're
supporting disabled people with 150
pounds and that that is coming on stream
in september that is really important
and sits alongside the opportunities for
growth that we also hope will benefit
disabled people because i was talking
only last week
in studios
around
around the way that we're helping more
people into employment and that is vital
okay good to talk to you sadly we're out
of time it's great to see